oh hey there how you been good good yeah
me too
2016 and we are back from vacation just
a quick reminder of who we are I am Phil
Molina that's my name in case you forgot
it and everything you see on this
channel comes from just me and my buddy
Ted over there hi Ted
yeah Ted's editing a video right now
while I shoot this because we are always
working on videos but that means it's
just the two of us we got to pick and
choose very carefully what we're gonna
give our time to and 2016 is gonna make
us make some really tough decisions cuz
holy crap there is so much good stuff
coming out this year and you're not
exactly sure what is good that you
should care about this year don't worry
that's the point of this video but I
actually also want your input on this in
fact I need it because our little
channel here it's called new rock stars
because we think that the rock stars are
today are whatever the internet cares
about and you watching this high yet
you're the internet while I think I've
got a pretty good gauge for what those
things might be and maybe even on some
stuff that isn't so popular but it's so
worth it like black mirror for instance
you got to watch that I'm just one
ruggedly handsome man and you are who we
make the things for so after this video
do me a favor actually and yourselves a
little favor too because we make this
for you fill out this poll that I made
it's asking what you care about in 2016
got all kinds of TV shows and movies in
there but there's also a write-in
section in case I forgot something but
you also write in anything you want if
thousands if you write in there that you
care about the iPhone 7 and 2016 and you
want to know if they're actually gonna
get rid of the headphone jack or you
learnt know what's going on with like
Hyperloop trains any of that stuff I
would be down to cover that too just let
me know in that poll you can also tweet
at me at fimo but okay on to the general
list of what people are probably gonna
care a lot about in 2016 again they'll
voice your opinion in that poll and then
we'll know for sure let's do it January
so starting off at the very beginning of
this year if you're anything like me you
just spent your entire break binging
making
and then the only time you took a break
from that binging was to watch the
Sherlock Christmas special it came out
on New Year's Day the crazy thing about
it is that it for Sherlock this year
there's no new episodes until at least
January 2017 sorry Kenny where Elsa
marks the return of almost all of our
big superhero shows especially the DC
ones
Supergirl already came back on January
4th though I'm not actually watching
that at the moment you let me know if
you think I should and then starting
January 19th we get three days in a row
of premieres on the CW with flash that
day arrows back the very next day and
the day after that the 21st you get the
premiere of legends of tomorrow I've
actually heard pretty good things about
that show but my guess is you will like
it if you like flash and you won't if
you don't February is super exciting
because we get the freakin Deadpool
movie and by the way just like how
Deadpool claims in his recent TV ad it's
telling me a good romantic movie you
could take your significant other to go
see it's the beginning of Valentine's
Day weekend February 12 but if your lame
date is like no I don't like r-rated
blood-soaked superhero movies fine yeah
you'll just have to settle for zombies
and the beginning of the absolute best
storyline from The Walking Dead comics
it's about to get so good that comes
back on little Cupid's birthday February
14 Gotham makes its return on the
unluckiest birthday of all February 29th
but I might be a little bit more excited
about what happens on February 26
that's the Netflix premiere of fuller
house do not judge me I have just a
morbid curiosity about it I have no idea
how the home of Daredevil and Jessica
Jones and house of cards is gonna do
this stupid little show from my
childhood
if it's as awkward as that video of
Kimmy Gibbler dancing I have to watch it
I'll be honest you're probably gonna
check it out - oh also did you know that
they legitimately try to get the Scarlet
Witch herself elizabeth Olsen to come in
and play that part that her sisters
won't play Michelle tanner it's totally
true the producers went to Elizabeth
Olsen's agent and her agent was like
yeah no of course she's not gonna do
that
that said I actually can't blame them
for trying like what if they let her
keep her Scarlet Witch powers
be very cool but we've also got a big
surprise for you that should come out
around that time if you're a fan of our
Game of Thrones prank check out our
channel in March but also check it out
before March and also after March
marching forward we get the return of
agents of shield on March 8th I gotta
say I've actually been really feeling
agents of shield lately like I do think
it's a bit of a roller coaster of a show
but these last few episodes at least
have really like messed with my heart
but like an A in the good way I'm
excited for it also it's not exactly
clear when but somewhere around this
time is my best guest for the new season
of reckon Kimmy Schmidt and I will be
honest I kind of forgot this show
existed until it popped into my head
when Luke Cage kind of mentioned it you
can't fix me but still I'm actually
excited for it to come back okay and now
contrary to what was earlier reported
March 18th marks the return of daredevil
season 1 is up there as some of the best
stuff that Marvel has ever done and that
long hallway fight scene it's absolutely
legendary
that said this shows been known more for
like its drama kind of than its action
but considering this upcoming season is
gonna add Elektra and freakin Punisher I
think the action on the show is about to
jump like a thousand steps up I also
have a good feeling that we'll probably
see Jessica Jones and maybe Luke Cage
somewhere in there it's all just
overwhelming it's too much just
legitimately one of the things I'm most
excited for in 2016 I just can't even
comprehend it oh and thank God earlier
reports were wrong because initially the
rumor was that this was gonna come out a
week later on March 25th the same day as
Batman vs Superman
and my god like that would be like if a
father was having two newborn twin
babies but somehow they're being born at
different hospitals and he has to decide
which one to go to and like the one he
doesn't go to is gonna resent him
forever and like Paulie got like mixed
up into drugs and stuff I think this
metaphor holds up but yeah March 25th
Batman vs. Superman this is a fight
we've been debating since elementary
school like Batman's brain versus
Superman's brawn I honestly can't wait
to see batfleck I hear he's
right and if that is the case then we're
about to get a ton more batman movies
again that's awesome also according to
zack snyder there's all sorts of stuff
that seemingly overloaded trailer did
not show and he says that's all gonna
get people really psyched I think just
expect this thing to dominate the
cultural conversation for a long time
and deservedly in fact I think that's a
whole be talking about for that whole
month because not much else happens that
I know until the next really huge thing
which might shut everyone up boom April
24 season six of Game of Thrones the
show that left us with a cliffhanger
that at the time we didn't know with a
cliffhanger then there were all these
rumors in the off season and yeah Game
of Thrones taught us that all men must
die but now we're asking must all men
stay dead I've been reading the books
for like the past month I should be
caught up before the show comes back and
I've already got so many juicy theories
you would be surprised how many clues
are even in like the very first book
about things that still haven't even
happened yet I'm just so excited to make
those videos for you guys they're gonna
be great but let's move on I'm gonna
take a guess and say right around here I
think that's where we're gonna see
season two of fear The Walking Dead I'm
guessing that because if it comes out in
its 15 episodes long that would lead
directly into season freakin 7 of The
Walking Dead so it just seems like good
timing I'm actually really excited for
it because well the first season I know
wasn't for everyone but I'm a big fan of
watching how people respond to outbreaks
and disasters so it completely worked on
me and season two is gonna address what
every smartass comes up with as an idea
of what they would do if a zombie
apocalypse really happened it's gonna
explore getting on a freaking boat and
seeing how you do in the ocean that's
something we've never really seen in a
zombie TV short movie that I can think
of and I can't wait to see what happens
I'm just as a reminder in their universe
you don't need to get bit to turn you
just need to die so no matter what
they're in trouble
May 6 a.m. and suggest that this is
gonna be the biggest box office weekend
of the year because you guessed it
that's Captain America Civil War and I
do not know if there's anything that can
get us more hype for this movie in fact
it just hit me the other day that the
civil war story in the comics it's
interesting but it doesn't exactly feel
like it lives up to its potential then I
realized that the movie
is taking the really great premise and
letting go the stuff that's not so great
and it put it all in the hands of the
guys that gave us a Winter Soldier and
ah that just made me excited all over
again and I'm just realizing again it's
the beginning of Marvel's phase three
like just the beginning of it what a
time to be alive
I just love life there is only one movie
that I can think that maybe has a chance
of performing better than Civil War it's
actually not Batman vs Superman though I
think that movie is also gonna be mega
huge we'll get to that other movie
though in just a little bit moving on if
you are a fan of epic comic book
storylines in general the hits just keep
coming because at the end of that month
may 27 bum x-men apocalypse the recent
trailer actually looked pretty damn good
and since we all just fell in love with
Poe Dameron I'm not really excited to
see what Oscar Isaac is gonna pull off
with apocalypse oh and one thing to get
you even more excited you might not know
this one of apocalypses powers is to
actually give new stronger powers to
other mutants specifically his horseman
and one of his horsemen in this movie is
Magneto I think we're gonna see the most
badass version of magneto yet and he's
already been amazing in those movies I
can't wait know I technically can wait
but only because I have to because of
the laws of physics and time side note
though my mom's birthday is May 27 so
Thank You x-men for giving me the
perfect celebration for her